antisocial personality disorder includes
both sociopaths and Psychopaths they
have some things in common but there are
very distinct things I'm dr. Ali Mattu
clinical psychologist and today we're
gonna be looking at mental illness in
movies in New York does it remind you
that's manipulative I don't talk about
it they coming back
aliens maybe can you stop so that's kind
of a pretty good example of trauma right
there and I just catch my breath person
now he's starting to feel some panic
he's been triggered this is a really
good example of how everyday situations
can trigger someone and the other person
might not even know that they're
triggering someone's trauma
I said stop doing that I'm supported
you're gonna freak me out I really love
Marvel movies and Iron Man 3 is one of
my favorites because it's such a good
representation of anxiety here we see
Tony experiencing panic hyperventilation
is a pretty core symptom of panic we see
tony stark avoiding a lot of situations
that are difficult for him and that's a
big hallmark of anxiety it's a good
example of trauma because trauma happens
when fundamental belief you have has
been challenged in some way he's always
been able to engineer his way out of
danger and this is the first time he
couldn't in the movie his anxiety just
sort of seems to resolve itself and we
don't really see how it's resolved
itself but I like what they show us in
terms of the examples of anxiety and
trauma there
okay I haven't seen split yet but I
really want to see it so this isn't
looks like another disassociative
identity disorder it's kind of
interesting idea is like vlogging as
your different personalities to yourself
so accurate representation different
tone of voice different presentation
different way of talking different way
of sitting no idea what's about to
happen but it's kind of interesting
what's unusual about this example is his
different personalities seem to be
talking to each other some personalities
can interact with each other but to this
level of communication and coordination
probably not and disassociative identity
disorder is also very controversial some
people think it's a representation of
schizophrenia and that is a big myth the
confusion comes from the word
schizophrenia schizophrenia means split
mind and that refers to the split
between what's really happening and what
someone's experiencing in their mind
with hallucinations he has kidnapped
these other women it's M night Shyamalan
film in this kind of stuff you suspend
your disbelief a little bit more but
this is where a lot of people get ideas
about mental illness I don't think a lot
of people take it too seriously but it
is perpetuating some myths I haven't
seen beautiful mine in these many years
but I remember really liking
oh my gosh
this is like he was okay so he's
experiencing a visual hallucination he's
seeing something that isn't really there
and it's much more common to have
auditory hallucinations to hear things
but some people do experience visual
hallucinations
a big part of schizophrenia is confusion
and and fear and not quite understanding
what's happening and I think we're
seeing a good example of that so one of
the things about schizophrenia is
learning how to identify your symptoms
and learning what is an hallucination
and what's actually real John Nash in
the scene realizes that one of his
hallucinations never ages that could be
effective form of coping for him I've
heard other people say if my dog is not
reacting to something then I know that's
my illness that's a pretty realistic way
to cope with it one of my only issues
with a beautiful mind is at the end
there is sort of this message that you
can sort of out-think schizophrenia and
that isn't it's not the most realistic
what's really great about a beautiful
mind is it shows someone who has
schizophrenia who is not violent and
that's a big stereotype about
schizophrenia most people who have
mental illness are not violent they're
much more likely to be the victims of
violence than they are someone who might
be violent themselves shadow games do
sally forces 100 a night to a lot of
people who have autism
do you see visual patterns to a much
higher degree than people who don't have
autism 4 6 101 92 but they also really
struggle with social interaction do you
remember eyes a little book yeah you
start from the beginning yeah how far
you get Chetan I think Tom Cruise's
character is a good representation of
how hard it can be for people who don't
have autism to understand it maybe were
supposed to be
table before the pancakes we have an
order yet right
of course when they bring in maple syrup
after thank you that's it meeting things
to be a certain way and then getting
really emotionally overwhelmed when
they're not like that that happens a lot
with autism no toothpick come definitely
definitely not good I like that
representation it does a good job of
showing the differences in how someone
who has autism versus someone who
doesn't have autism how they see the
world and also the challenges of working
together and understanding each other
the only thing I don't like about this
representation it does show more of a
narrow view of the functioning of
someone who has autism now we know it's
it's a spectrum and people are all over
on that spectrum but that's more just
representative of when this movie was
made other than that I think it shows
those main features of autism the focus
on visual patterns on logic a little bit
of rigidity and difficulty with social
interactions it shows those really well
I haven't seen this in a long time but I
remember liking its representation it's
a middle of the night so he's clearly
having a hard time falling asleep which
sleep problems are a big part of bipolar
disorder the three o'clock what are you
doing I look at here but this is all
your [ __ ] and he's focused on on
something trying to solve a problem we
call that goal directed activity which
is much more common when people might be
experiencing manic symptoms this is also
a great example of how bipolar can
impact families are you going to my
study it's a bit more irritable more
frustrated and more upset that can also
really happen when someone is more manic
bipolar is all about moving fast or
moving slow we're definitely seeing that
fast part right here this is a really
quick escalation of stuff but this kind
of sequence of events can happen with
bipolar disorder when someone is manic
wouldn't happen this quickly but you
know it's a movie that was pretty good
very quick escalation wouldn't happen
that quickly but it does a good job of
showing us that experien
of being manic we also see a lot of that
emotional sensitivity intensity of the
emotions one of the biggest triggers for
bipolar disorder diff you're not
sleeping as much as you used to or if
you have trouble falling asleep it can
have a huge impact on your mood I love
Sherrod I think for now we'll downgrade
you to casual acquaintances no more than
three plan to social encounters a year
and always in Joan's presence I have
your contact details I will be
monitoring about you you're a bloody
psychopath high functioning sociopath
with your number that is such a good
line I love that because that speaks to
this difference between sociopaths and
Psychopaths there is a difference in in
how we use those terms both categories
they might break rules or break the law
the difference with a sociopath is they
can form connections with other people
Sherlock definitely has a relationship
with Watson he definitely cares about
him so he does have relationships he
doesn't just simply manipulate people
the thing that's a little bit less
realistic is people who are sociopaths
they tend to be more reactive more
impulsive more emotional than
Psychopaths who are more cold-blooded
more tempered more calculating this
Sherlock I think he's a bit more on the
autism spectrum he sees patterns doesn't
interact with people the same way that
other people do he's not impulsive like
we would think of many sociopaths I
remember being so low - hey but I made
him smarter sure so we're seeing a lot
of examples of how she's manipulated
other people there's a callousness a
lack of emotion there we were happy
pretending to be other people we were
the happiest
we knew that lack of emotion lack of
empathy ability to manipulate other
people to get what you want this is very
characteristic of antisocial personality
disorder especially breaking the law
murdering people Walker bouncier cool
girl there's a really intense you think
I'd let him destroy me and end up
happier than ever
so that was really just hearing her I
felt I felt like goose bumps it just
felt so cold so calculated I would be
very nervous around someone like that
it's a pretty good example of antisocial
personality disorder that's the
technical clinical term that we use it's
not the term most people use with terms
that come up our sociopaths and
Psychopaths this is actually example of
someone who is a psychopath being very
cold-blooded being able to manipulate
other individuals not forming strong
attachments unless it's to get what you
want that type of manipulation that's
much more associated with what people
call psychopaths they can work on Wall
Street and be really good scientists the
attachment from other people actually
helps them to do their job they don't
have to be killers most of the stories
that we see are about murderers and
that's not that's not realistic what's
so cool about movies is they can make it
easier for us to have conversations
about mental illness mental illness is
just one part of of who we are as one
part of our identity but it's not the
whole story
and now I need to go get a hug because I
feel very scared that was a scary movie
you
[Music]